DAVE HAKSTOL WORKING WITH RON
HAKSTOL AND A NSWI FOR THE KRAK
SEATTLE KRACKEN WIHAS BEEN REAL
HEATING UP THERE BY PHILIPP  TH
DAYLIGHT BUT PHILIPP GRUBAUER
SLAMS THE DOOR.
>> RIGHT-HANDED SHOT.
RODRIGUES  AND THE
PRESSURE FROM
GATHERS IT UR NET.
>> WHEN YOU MAKE THE MISTAKE
SEVEN MONTHS LATER NAMED
PENGUINS GRETHIS
ATTACK.
DUMOULIN BACK OVER AND A POWER
CARRIED
BOX.
A GOLDEN CHANCE FOR THE KRAKEN
AND ON BY LETANG.
AT LOOK FLEURY AFTER A
SHOT SAVE OF THE NIGHT OF JORDA
EBERLE.
MINER
AND SPARKLING.
>> HE SCORES
DEFLECTS IT IN.
THERE IS THE REWAY OF THE SHOT
AND YOU IMPEDE THE GOALTENDER'S
VISION IN A CHANCE FOR
THE FF
CARTER.
WON EIGHT OF 12.
ONE OF THE DEFENSIVE ZONE IT AN
BY JARRY.
AND ANOTHER GAME AND WANTS
TO